hey guys it's the clothes lucky and I'm
Joey and we are gonna answer the
Internet but first I want to show you my
Snooki knees you're all gonna look hot
in them so check them out and also we
have our live podcast show happening
April 24th at the Count Basie Theatre in
Red Bank New Jersey at 8 p.m.
yes Queen would you rather date an ugly
rich dude or a poor good-looking guy
very rich very ugly very poor very hot
rich and ugly well Joey did actually get
with a rich guy for free shoes for free
sure they're really expensive shoes and
I've got on all fours and let him eat
his butt yeah I appreciate it so he was
75 years old 25 I still have the shoes
today there were like seven are dollar
shoes it was worth it would you rather
be a bad kisser or give bad head I mean
neither do I have to pick I'd rather be
a bad kisser you can't make money by
kissing someone
yeah rather be a bad kisser it's like
there goes my college fund
would you rather everybody talk about
you behind your back or never talk about
you at all talk about it behind your
back never talk about you at all you
don't talk about me on cam I am all
press is good press okay
you have to choose between sex on the
first date or sex on the 19th date is
that 19 or 10 10th date your 10 suck
what are you picking all right so sex on
the 10th day or the first date the first
date because yeah I don't want to waste
my time
yeah but knowing that it just doesn't
click ed I would you the first date as
well
same preferably before dinner how much
money would it take for you to not know
how to read I mean we're not far off
yeah why do we know how to react I don't
care how much can get money if we don't
know how to read how much money would it
take for you to know how to read oh I
don't care I don't need to read I'll
take a hundred bucks who reads [ __ ] that
Bobby Brown would you rather have ugly
shoes or ugly underwear ugly underwear
except with my granny panties right now
yeah
would you you yeah would you would you
rather your partner always have a huge
bush or you always have a huge are you I
used to have a huge bush Oh God I want
my partner to have a huge bush I'll take
the huge bush cuz I don't want to be in
there I don't like here oh I do I want
to bury my nose in it would your parents
have sex every night join in one time to
make it stop so are you freaks well my
mother's dead so I'll pick the UH one
time to make it no I don't want to [ __ ]
my parents I'll just watch what doing
that you're gonna have to watch him do
it you want to [ __ ] your dad thetic not
again I'll just watch once is enough I
got my bike and now it's fun
can you imagine
it was a huffy would you rather every
time you come it comes out of your mouth
or it's a tube your bowels work so every
time I just has to either come out of my
mouth or I have to come well I was just
two liters that seems like a lot of
cleanup and I am a comm Hungry Horse so
I build jizz it on my mouth oh my god
yeah final answer why are we long at the
house I don't know
would you rather prove aliens are real
that's she likely our proof ghosts are
real ghosts aliens why what ghosts are
real like we don't just then you know
that you're gonna you're not gonna
you're gonna be dead and meet somewhere
else
you bet a lien it's like there's a [ __ ]
I ain't gonna baseship I'm not going up
to the station
aliens first shirks I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] outta my seat good would you rather
have no friends or no internet well I
think we're both in that situation yeah
we don't have any I can't pay my bills
I'd say no friends yeah I don't want any
friends I only have this one and she's
pregnant so it's not even a real friend
anymore if you could bring back one if
you could bring back one person from the
dead who would it be your mom no I need
to see her I would be he's gonna cry oh
um I don't know I guess so if I had to
but then I picked someone more fun I
would bring my cat rocky back cuz we
used to make out and I loved him
okay would you rather walk in on
you read it would you rather walk in on
your dad having sex with a dog or a dog
having sex through that oh I rather just
daddy my Papi's more of a bottom so I
would say he's getting yet he's getting
railed by a masterhood yeah I'd rather
it be funnier because then you're seeing
your dad's peepee with a dog they abused
the dogs getting off and enjoying myself
back in my dad's [ __ ] it's an animal
abuse so the dog getting lost
yeah for sure final answer would you
rather a guy last 30 seconds or an hour
30 seconds or separate and like fine for
that yeah 30 seconds yeah I have places
to be
would you rather never have sex again or
never eat your favorite food oh never
have sex oh I haven't had sex since 2012
yeah my poor Joey
yeah okay I'll take a step shells please
with extra cheese would you rather be
married to someone extremely interactive
or be extremely attractive
I can't I'd rather be the hot one to say
about that [ __ ] cheating he's
hot exactly same that's a lot of drama
I'd rather be the hot one fan
would you rather get punched by Mike
Tyson or have to sound like him for the
rest of your life where am I getting
probably want to get punched I want to
get in points how many a punch in my
fart box by M oh well I think it's still
amazing it's Mike Tyson all right I'll
take it
would you rather be able to have sex
with anyone you want or a teleport
anywhere in the world
teleport sex isn't all that yeah I would
teleport same same well this was lovely
you